me
[音楽]
皆さん
お寺は好きですか
よ失礼しました突然お寺が好きかって聞かれて
好きで s って即答できる方はなかなかいらっしゃいますよね
それにそもそもお寺が好きかどうか舌へ編まれる聞かれることがないと思います
でもなかにはお寺が好きだよって方はいらっしゃるんじゃないでしょうか
例えばお寺の古い時代の仏像や日本庭園なんかは日本人だけでなく外国の方の中にも
大好きだよって方が結構いらっしゃると思います
実は日本には全国で7万7000もの数のお寺があると言われています
日本のコンビニの総数が5万7000点と言われていますからそれよりも2番も多い
ですから
どれだけお寺の数が多かったことが分かりますよね
でも
コンビニは週に何回か
中には毎日空って方もいらっしゃると思うんですがお寺はどうですか
羞恥
いや8月に一度だってお寺に行くよという方あまりいらっしゃらないんじゃない
でしょうかね
死確定遠い存在
それが今のお寺なんだと思います
そもそも4月かどうか以前に入っ
皆さんにとってお寺といい場所
亡くなった方のお墓参りや封じていくことが多い
つまりあまり楽しく行く場所ではありませんよね
でも最近は楽しく受けちゃう寺少しずつですが増え始めています
例えばこのうちの寺法多山尊永寺と言いますがうちのお寺もその一つです
実は今やもう星光代という
秋の夜を楽しむイベントが行われます
秋の虫の声を聞きながら満天の星空を眺めたり
大きな天体望遠鏡で星運や惑星を鑑賞する
とっても素敵なイベントじゃありませんか
でもこのイベント私たち落ちるの力だけで出来るわけではなくアマチュア天文家の方や
多くの市民の皆さんのご協力をいただいて初めてできるイベントなんです
それ以外にもほぼ一年中何かしらのイベントが行われている
豊かな自然の中にあって大変活気に満ちた音です
ではなぜ私がこうした取り組みをしている
別にたくさんイベントをしなくても十分お寺自体は成り立っているんですがそれでも
なぜこうした取り組みをしているのか
理由は2つです
1つ目の理由
それは
人々が集い
にぎわい楽しい場所
それがお寺の本来あるべき姿と私が信じているからです
かつてのテラー
100年ほど前のお寺は今の私たちが持っているお寺のイメージとは全然違ったんです
かつてのをテラー
特に地方のお寺はそこの地域コミュニティのよりどころだったんです
例えば寺子屋
という言葉が示すように
かつてのお寺はそこに住む人々の学びの場でもありました
また田舎の村で市場が+と言えばお寺の門前でありましたし
より家会合といえば
お寺のお堂や建物を借りて行われることが多かったようです
このようにかつてのお寺は人々の集いの場でもありました
また子どもの遊びかと言えばお寺の境内
地方巡業の芝居小屋がかかるのもお寺の中であることが多かったようですし
それ以外にもさまざまな娯楽の場としてお寺は用いられてきました
かつてのお寺は
人々の遊びの場でもあったんです
時代が降りこうした機能は学校やコミュニティセンター
あるいは娯楽施設に移されてきました
今のお寺は亡くなった方のための場所
お寺の仕事も
亡くなった方の霊事ぐらいお祀りすることがもっぱらだと思ってらっしゃる方が多いと
思います
お子さんの中にでさえそうした認識の方がたくさんいらっしゃいます
もちろんそれはそれでとても対決大切なことなんですが
かつてあった機能を放棄し続ける必要私は感じません
むしろ本来あるべきお寺の姿を取り戻し
今のお寺に融合した方が仏様の星を広げるのに役に立つ
そう私は考えているんです
二つ目の理由
それはこうした活動を通して多くの仲間に巡り合え
なにかをつくる楽しみ
時には苦しむ
いやもしかしたらその苦しみも楽しみなのかもしれませんが
そうした楽しみを分かち合う喜びがそこにあるからです
私は自分の寺でマネー
高校卒業するまで自分の寺のある町で育ちました
大学進学や修行のために8人間故郷を離れることになり
8年ぶりに帰郷した時にはただ懐かしいというだけではなく
走行何か激しい渇きにも似た寂しさを感じて自分の寺で働く傍らで
ただがむしゃらにそして様々なシーンで自分の町にん
そしてそこに住む人々に
関わってきました
そうした20代30代の過ごし方の中で
ますます私は自分の街が大好きないっ
ましたますそこに暮らす人々が大好きになりん
40歳で重職を迎えたときには自分の街だけではなく
世界で一番喜んでもらえるを選び
世界で一番楽しんでもらえるお寺をん
作ることが私の使命だとさえ思えるようになっていたんです
今の活動支え苦楽を共にする仲間の多くはそうした私とまちづくりの中で出会った人が
多いです
まぁこんな風に話したけどなんだかすごく自信満々
順風満帆に聞こえるかもしれませんが実はそうでもありません
結構がでいかないこともあります
時には心にプレイヤーの良いが生じないわけでもありません
そうした時に私は励ますまた
前へ前へと進めてくれるものがあります
それが今活動を共にする仲間たちから聞くことができる
ありがとう
という感謝の言葉や
てのシーンという喜びの言葉なんです
そう
私は大丈夫まだまだ行っちゃいる
そんな風に思えるのはこの言葉のおかげかもしれません
法多山で毎年開催されているイベントにコトコト市所があります
十数年の長きに渡って行われこの地域のコミュニティマーケットの草分け的存在の
イベントです
その主催者の方から
虫
あなたのお寺でコトコト市を引き受けてくれなかったらこんなに長くは続かなかった
でしょうし
それにこの地域に人が集ってマーケットを開催する文化も根付かなかったかもしれませ
ん
本当にありがとうございますという感謝の言葉を
毎回毎回いただきます
また私の友人えー
まちづくりや今を行っているお寺作りとは何の縁もない仕事の人間なんですが
40歳過ぎてなんだかつまらないというので私たちの活動に誘ったところあります
実は今年の夏もうちのお寺で開催された
お化け屋敷の設定4夜遅くまで二人でやっていた時
彼が突然に遭いアーバイって言い出したので同社
何か失敗したで聞くと
楽しくてしょうがない
ここに人が入ってドキドキワクワクするかと思うと楽しくてしょうがない
50歳近くになって
こんなに楽しい想いができると思わなかった
誘ってくれてありがとう
その中での言葉を聞いて少しウルッときてしまいました
今の活動や取り組みに対して素晴らしい
斬新だ
そうした賞賛の声も確かに嬉しいんですが
それ以上に
活動を共にする仲間たちから聞くことができるありがとうという感謝の言葉や他の
シーンという喜びの言葉が私の何よりの励みになっています
さてもうそろそろ皆さんお気づきかもしれませんがなぜ私がこうした取り組みをして
いるのか
今入ったりいう意味
私が大好きなんです
私が
人が集ってにぎやかで楽しいお寺が大好きなんです
確かに
お寺という空間は
静かで申請であるべきだという方もいらっしゃると思います
またそういう出るのが好きだよという方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
静かな空間
といえば
中に誰もいなくて更新員とした状態のことを
ガラーンとしたと彼がランドと言いますよね
このがランドということがなんですが漢字で書くと
ガランと同
そうなんですこれ実はどちらもんお寺のお堂を指す言葉なんですね縦もの一つかと思い
ます
akko どちらのお堂の中普段
段あり無力て神韻としてますよねそうした状態がこのがらんどうの号幻だと言われてい
ます
確かにお寺の本堂なんかは普段は
何もなくてなんかガラーンとしてますよね
もちろんこれはご本尊様を待っ制する大切な空間ですし様々な儀式にも使われますから
普段はガラーンとしていて当たり前なんですが
それでも私はやっぱり賑やかで楽しいお寺が大好きなんです
それに
お寺の中でも新部下であるべき場所が静かであればいいと私は思っているんです
私はこう考えます
お寺はほとで様の為
だけの場所ではない
お寺は亡くなった方のためだけの場所ではない
打てれば今生きている人のために
そしてそんな人々のためにもあるべき場所なんです
それに最初に言いましたが
お寺全国で7万7000もあるんですよ
東京のド真ん中に入っ
いなか村に
ですからその場所にあったお寺の活用法とコードが必ずあると思う
例えば
大都会の真ん中に緑豊かなオアシスを出現させることができます
例えば方のはない
田舎の小さな集落でジャズライブだってできちゃいます
今全国のお寺が少しずつですが変わろうとしています
かつてそうであったように
そこの地域コミュニティのよりどころとしていっ
そこに暮らし生きる人々のための場所としてい
でゾーン私のお寺がそうであるように
ドテラだけが頑張ってもダメなんです
皆さんの力が必要なんです
来なさいです
皆さんの持っているお寺のイメージをガラッと変えちゃいましょう
聖書の一節に
叩けよさらば開かれんという言葉があります
いや仏教徒の私がそういう言葉引用していけないのかもしれませんが
それでももし
そこにお寺があったら勇気を持ってそれも潜ってください
そこに新しい楽しみがあるかも知れませ
そこにあなたの知らない喜びがあるかもしれません
少なくともうちのてるは大歓迎です
どうぞいらしてください
そして私たちと一緒に
新しい楽しみ
まだ知らない喜びを共に作っていきましょう
[拍手]